en russie une bonne surprise pour
vladimir poutine
héros d'une chanson à sa gloire
interprété par un girls band local titre
de la chanson genre eu un comme poutine
plein de force et qui ne voient pas la
surprise c'est que la chanson fait un
tabac a surtout chez les jeunes
reportage à mouscou dominique derda
france brice est inconnue il ya encore
quelques semaines irina larissa et la
tâche à sont en passe de devenir en
russie de véritables stars grâce à cette
chanson la seule et l'unique de leur
répertoire que les radios diffusent à
longueur de journée depuis sa sortie
et c'est avec un bel enthousiasme
qu'elle enchaîne les interviews et
répète à l'envi que oui vraiment la
dîmière poutine est bien l'homme idéal
celui dont rêvent toutes les jeunes en
tant qu'individu il me plaît beaucoup
le sympathique jeune énergique normal
quoi
ces femmes voudraient toujours avoir à
ses côtés quelqu'un sur qui elle puisse
compter sur toi maman j'espère vis la
protéger une autre chanson ces
politiciens ce rôle depuis son accession
au pouvoir l'obscur agent du kgb s'est
peu à peu des rides et humaniser sous
l'impulsion de ses conseillers on l'a vu
en judokas en pilote de chasse mais
aussi et surtout un homme du peuple
simple et chaleureux à en croire ses
auteurs la chanson ne serait que le
reflet de son image publique celle que
la télévision strictement contrôlé par
le kremlin donne du président poutine
occupe réellement une grande place dans
la vie des russes des informations à la
télé commence toujours par lui on nous
montre tout ce qu'il sait nous rachète
tout ce qui lie c'est comme ça ça fait
partie de notre mentalité
ce club est l'un des plus branchés de la
capitale pas les gens n'ont plus à faire
dans la propagande pourtant c'est ici
que le groupe s'est produit la première
fois et le portrait de poutine oeuvres
d'un peintre d'avant-garde trône en
évidence dans la salle de restaurant
comprenez bien que nous on n'a ni
marilyn monroe nuit et 10 presley
lui-même mickey mouse on n'a rien sur
une poutine se sait tout
irina larissa et natacha elles
n'attendent plus qu'une chose rencontrer
enfin en chair et en os celui dont elle
chante les louanges